well when you measure temperature you
talk about things that are cold or hot
for example the the air in this room has
a certain temperature what we measure is
the speed at which particles that make
up this air molecule air molecules
what at what speed they move so
something that's hot on a molecular
scale those molecules are vibrating
around and what i don't mean is that a
whole
bunch of gas moves in one direction or
the other what i mean is the random
movement of the little molecules and
they're moving in different ways okay so
they might be moving just translation
they're moving backwards and forwards in
three dimensions uh they might be
spinning around really quickly okay so
that's also hot that's another way of
being hot so if i had a little
microscope that allowed me to see each
individual molecule
in the air then i could measure for each
molecule how fast it moves
this movement would be in random
directions and also
the speed would be different for
different molecules but there'd be an
average speed
and that average speed would be the
measure of temperature so to give you a
sense of scale the average speed of a
molecule in this room
is approximately that of an airplane and
then if you have something like carbon
dioxide which is this shape
it might be vibrating backwards and
forwards so hot can mean different
things hot is simply a measure of how
much energy something has and that
energy takes a translational form it
takes a rotational form and it takes a
vibrational form and it's actually it's
this vibrational form which is giving us
all the problems with global warming
because all that that infrared energy
which is coming from the earth happens
to be at exactly the right wavelength to
cause carbon dioxide to vibrate like
this and so the carbon dioxide warms up
so the temperature of the atmosphere
increases and gets locked into the
atmosphere cold means absolutely the
opposite cold means that things are
getting stiller and stiller so first of
all you lose the vibration first of all
things
get locked into their basic shape
then you lose the rotation so things
stop rotating and become static and then
finally
you lose the translation and things
eventually get down to very very still
now of course and and when they're
stationary that's absolute zero but of
course we can't do that we can't get to
stationary uh there's certain laws of
quantum mechanics which we're not going
to go into i understand right but there
are certain laws of quantum mechanics
which means that it can't be stationary
in this laboratory we go to extremes in
this in a way of temperatures and we
make here
temperatures we produce gases that have
temperatures that are
much lower than anything you'd find in
nature we can take temperatures right
down to 100 micro kelvin a million times
colder than our cold day that's quite
remarkable and at those temperatures we
really start to see quantum mechanics
playing in effect we're playing a very
significant role in what we're talking
about when we're talking about
temperature we use laser light
to
shine this light onto
a collection of atoms we arrange our our
laser light in such a way that we
actually
directly work on that on that speed of
these particles
and reduce the speed to almost
zero and at that temperature
the whole temperature scale stops really
meaning something and what you're really
just talking about is how much energy
the molecules have so what you see here
is these these um
steel parts and then some some point we
also have
glass so we have windows in this
and
what happens is it it's airtight
so um the air in this room won't get
into this
and then on on this side of the
apparatus we have a whole bunch of
things covered in tin foil and these
things
are pumps
so basically like vacuum cleaners just
better ones and they they evacuate this
vacuum chamber here the steel chamber
and hang on what's this
this is something that allows me someone
at my height to actually approach this
without slaying my head into
what i just did here
um
this is one of the few things in this
lab that i built personally
and i'd like to say that this vacuum is
really good vacuum it's really um
the the density of of
molecules inside this chamber is a
million times a million times less than
this room so the pressure is that much
lower in there so there's really almost
nothing in there and then what we do is
we put in
a few of these rubidium atoms that we
like
and then from the outside and that's why
where the windows and the glass comes
into play we shine laser beams for
example these
mirrors that you see all over the place
here
they
allow us to shine
laser light from all directions so this
is a cloud of half a billion rubidium
atoms
and we shine laser light from all
different directions onto this cloud
and this is arranged in a smart way and
that that that actually
means that these atoms are slowed down
by
by this light they they absorb
light from these beams and they re-emit
light that has slightly more energy and
that's how they become
slow and slow means cold
so it's about
a few million times colder than the air
in this room but what peter showed you
well we're gonna go much colder than
that so we're at that temperature now
but in the next six months we expect to
go a thousand times colder than that
down to a hundred nano kelvin which is a
billion times colder than our original
cold day and at that temperature
everything is quantum mechanical and the
whole world as we intuitively understand
it no longer exists we start to see
really different weird effects coming
into play and that's that's what gets me
out of bed in the morning that's what i
find truly exciting about being a
physicist